bonjour alors on m'a dit aujourd'hui
qu'il y avait pas mal d'enseignants dans
la salle mais surtout beaucoup
d'étudiants est ce que c'est le cas il
ya beaucoup des tiers alors du coup je
vais m'adresser bon sur un peu à tout le
monde
est ce que ce genre de figure là me
rappelle quelque chose
ce que ça vous rappelle le bon souvenir
déjà
je suis en train dé n'auront donc pas de
bons souvenirs même des cauchemars oui
bon c'est vrai que bon même pour le
certains adultes ça laisse des séquelles
à l'état d'où ça peut laisser pas mal de
mauvais souvenirs mais à l'époque pour
moi et mes camarades lorsque nous
révisions nous étions sur les bancs de
l'université c'était la même chose nous
avions pas mal de problème avec ce genre
de matières qui ont énormément
énormément de détails beaucoup de
contenu et nous avions comme finalement
comme gros problème c'était finalement
d'avoir de la hauteur d'avoir du recul
sur ces choses là parce que quand on
regarde de plus près notamment ici avec
l'exemple de la biochimie ça peut faire
mal
ça peut être très spécifique ça peut
être vraiment dur appréhender bon
heureusement avec de l'acharnement pour
certains la persévérance pour d'autres
on a pu passer ces obstacles et
finalement réussir par la suite
notamment
moi je suis devenu enseignant à
l'université et paradoxalement j'ai été
amené à moi même devoir enseigner ces
matières là mes propres étudiants avec
tout son lot de difficultés et avant
d'intégrer l'université
je me suis j'ai fait quelques années en
collège et en lycée et je me suis
intéressé aux sciences cognitives et
notamment sur l'apprentissage et que
disent les sciences cognitives sur
l'apprentissage c'est que finalement
pour bien apprendre apprendre de manière
efficace mais il ya plusieurs grands
principes à respecter notamment le
principe de la tension les étudiants
doivent être pleinement attentif des
étudiants doivent être également
pleinement engagé dans ce qu'ils font
également ils doivent pouvoir avoir ce
que l'on appelle un retour immédiat
d'information c'est à dire que ils sont
en train de comprendre quelque chose ils
sont en train de la prendre et il faut
qu'il puisse avoir
on va dire en retour immédiat sûr est-ce
que j'ai bien compris ce que j'ai bien
appris est-ce que ce que je connais ce
que je maîtrise mon nom et en totale
adéquation avec le courroux le livre
dans lequel je travaille enfin dernier
principe important c'est ce que l'on
appelle la consolidation et ça notamment
la répétition permet de consolider ses
connaissances
alors avec le temps ces principes là on
était pour moi mon espèce de cahier des
charges
pour la réalisation des cours que je
peux en présentiel avec mes étudiants
puis les années durant les années
passant je me suis retrouvé donc avec
une grande diversité d'étudiants est un
problème récurrent qui revenue manière
on va dire presque chaque année c'est
que devant l'hétérogénéité des niveaux
et bien l'ensemble des étudiants ne
n'avais pas la même comment dire n'avait
pas les mêmes fondements n'avait pas ce
qu'on appelle les prérequis nécessaires
pour bien suivre les cours que je
faisais notamment et donc je perdais
beaucoup de temps à enseigner ses
fondamentaux qui n'en auraient dû être
acquis précédemment et donc en perdant
ce temps là je perd également du temps
moi même pour mes propres courts
importante est de résoudre ça mais je
regardais un petit peu sur internet ce
qui existait et je me suis aperçu que
beaucoup d'enseignants de collèges et de
lycées réalise des vidéos sur internet
des vidéos de cours qui récapitule des
points des points complet des fois même
là je me suis dit mais pourquoi pas
pourquoi pas réaliser des vidéos de
courtes vidéos qui me permettrait
d'avoir qui me permettrait de ne plus
perdre mon temps entre guillemets en
même temps qui permettrait d'aider les
étudiants à
un bon on va dire l'ensemble des
fondamentaux nécessaires poursuit et
donc me voici à créer ma propre et au
avec armé de mon ordinateur d'une
présentation de type powerpoint donc en
voix off je ne suis pas filmer moi-même
j'enregistre juste ma voix est armé
d'une tablette tactile pour justement à
noter des petits schémas à noter à
certaines choses et là je tourne la
première vidéo et avant de la poster à
l'ensemble de mes étudiants généralement
on aime bien avoir un petit retour
préalable avant peut-être de se faire
huer je ne sais pas je décide de
l'envoyer à mes proches alors là je
décide de l'envoyer notamment à ma
famille et à mon père qui dès qu'il a
reçu par mail me rappelle instantanément
par téléphone et me dit bon écoute on
voit bien on entend bien les schémas
sont claires c'est super continue bon je
tiens à préciser que vaut mon père ne
connaît absolument rien à la biochimie
ni à la biologie donc je me dis sur le
fond c'est que ça doit être bien et pour
pardon sur la forme et sur le fond par
contre je me suis dit bon il faudrait
peut-être que je demande à ma soeur qui
est une jeune enseignante en sciences et
vie de la terre et je lui envoie
également la vidéo est contraire de mon
père belle ne me rappelle pas donc
châtain en 24 heures voudrait qu'un tort
c'est moi qui l'appelle pour lui
demander alors qu'est ce que t'en as
pensé m répond la célèbre petite phrase
qui généralement vous fait très mal elle
me dit tu veux que je sois honnête avec
toi là j'y réponds bah oui elle me dit
bon écoute des vidéos ben t'as vidéo qui
fait plus de 10 15 minutes
elle est extrêmement lente elle
extrêmement monotone je te répète c'est
pas du tout dynamics et c'est quelque
chose enfin pour dire je me suis plutôt
ennuyé voire même j'ai décroché donc
gelé carrément arrêter ça fait mal
et là elle me rajoute la phrase suivante
samedi mais regarde le réseau social
important et des vidéos qui s'appelle
youtube regarde y'a plein de vidéastes
qui font des vidéos des sketches ces
comics et dynamique
c'est vivant inspire toi de tout ça pour
justement les faire rêver des étudiants
et des molécules et à bioshock
bon là je suis dit ok elle a du coup
elle me raccroche un brin grand chelem
cet iphone portable et partir de là je
me suis dit bon me suis posé la question
suivante est ce qu'il est possible
finalement de cours se voir en vidéo des
courts qui permettent
et là je vais reprendre mes quatre
grands principes vous avez ici sur la
gauche c'est-à-dire des vidéos qui vont
permettre aux étudiants d'être
pleinement attentif d'être pleinement
engagés d'avoir une consolidation des
connaissances et surtout d'avoir ce
qu'on appelle un retour d'information
immédiat est là pour cela
mais ça a été on va dire mon challenge
et je vais vous exposer brièvement un
petit peu comment est ce que j'ai tenté
d'intégrer ces principes dans les vidéos
à partir de ma vidéo de base que j'avais
fait qu'il n'était pas trop ça a priori
donc par rapport à l'attention d'abord
il ya ce qui est important c'est que
nous sommes des organismes sociaux
ça me plaisait être humain ça me donnait
des motions et nous avons besoin lorsque
l'on communique de voir la personne en
ont besoin de voir le visage de voir les
yeux de voir les mimiques de voir les
gestes tout ça c'est ce qu'on appelle
finalement de la communication non
verbale et c'est très important quand on
délivre un message donc dans les vidéos
c'est très important finalement d'avoir
quand même une personne deuxième point
et ça c'est vrai que la télévision des
émissions de télévision en très bien
compris savez ces espèces de variation
de plans des proches on éloigne et puis
ensuite on voit un plan à droite à
gauche donc notre cerveau est en
permanence en train de recalculer
l'image et nous on se retrouve comme ça
ap devant la télé a pas savoir à 2
heures du matin ouais je regarde je sais
pas pourquoi mais je regarde et tout ça
en fait sont des principes on va dire
neurophysiologiques liés au montage très
rapide qui vont faire que on ne sait pas
pourquoi mais on regarde donc pourquoi
pas pourquoi pas utiliser aussi ce genre
de dénis de temps en temps pour on va
dire essayer de captiver un minimum
l'étudiant avec des choses qui à la base
ne le font pas rêver
enfin les neurosciences et les sciences
pour montrer qu'il existait différents
types de deux profils notamment des
profils d'étudiants qui sont beaucoup
plus auditifs qui à entendre des
étudiants qui sont plus visuel qui eux
par contre m
voire du texte à voir des mois voire des
phrases et d'autres également aussi dans
le visuel mais qui préfère voir des
schémas donc des schémas quand on est
sur papier c'est pas animé alors que la
vidéo va permettre pourquoi pas d'avoir
des espaces d'animation et avec un
montage particulier on peut à la fois
faire oui de l'animation mais en même
temps faire apparaître petit à petit les
différentes étapes du cheminement et en
même temps toujours avec un montage on
rajoute la personne qui est en train
d'expliquer en plus et ça ça permet
d'avoir le couplage total enfin il
existe aussi une catégorie d'étudiants
que j'appelle les frustrés dont j'ai
fait partie
ce sont en fait des étudiants qui
peut-être c'est votre cas mais moi ça
l'a été dans certains cours quand on
aime bien suivre un cheminement d'un
enseignant on se dit tiens étape une
étape de d'accord je comprends bien mais
pendant qu'on est en train de comprendre
on n'est pas en train d'écrire
connaissez ça et à côté il ya les
étudiants qu'elle est en train d'écrire
oui c'est bon je comprends pas tout mais
j'écris tout comme ça chez moi je
pourrai reprendre
et là vous retrouvez un petit peu entre
les deux en train de vous dire ma ce
qu'est ce que je fais là c'est vrai que
la vidéo peut aider dans ce cas là et
pour peu que vous rajoutiez sous la
vidéo un petit lien avec un pdf avec
l'ensemble du texte qui est donnée et
l'ensemble des schémas terminé on n'a
plus du tout ces étudiants frustré donc
pour la tension quelques clés ici qui
peuvent permettre de renforcer des
vidéos à être plus attentif par rapport
à l'engagement ce qui est important
c'est pour l'étudiant c'est de connaître
pardon c'est aller un petit peu vite
c'est de connaître ce qu'on appelle son
pourquoi c'est à dire pourquoi est ce
qu'il est en train de regarder cette
vidéo pourquoi est ce qu'à ce moment-là
il entre ceux de regarder je ne sais pas
moi telle ou telle vidéo
il faut qu'ils puissent comprendre et
qu'il y ait du sens c'est pour ça c'est
vrai que quand on est dans un cours
traditionnels on peut avoir quand on a
beaucoup de petits détails de micro
détails on peut avoir des fois plusieurs
minutes dizaine de milles vendeurs avec
l'enseignant qui va parler de réactions
biochimiques ou quelle que soit la
matière de plein de petites choses très
pointilleuse et on en oublie finalement
pourquoi il ya ça c'était quoi le
général on est dans quelle situation
globale en est
et donc la vidéo peut permettre à tout
moment de temps ensemble de deux trois
minutes de revenir avec un plan large et
de dire au fait
là je suis en train d'expliquer ça sur
la biochimie mais c'est parce que
physiologiquement la personne vient de
manger où la personne est en jeu elle
est en train d'effectuer un jeune et
donc on explique de point de vue global
général quelque chose ensuite
et on va résumer ensuite sur de la
mécanique des petits détails et donc ça
permet à chaque fois d'avoir du sens ab
oui je sais pourquoi j'apprends ça donc
ça permet de comprendre la vidéo dans
son ensemble pour la consolidation
vous avez compris que la vidéo on peut
mettre stop on peut revenir en arrière
on peut avancer on peut faire plein de
choses donc ça c'est un avantage
indéniable pour les étudiants pour
qu'ils puissent réviser avec la
répétition notamment revoir et revoir
s'ils ont besoin d'avoir certains petits
passages qui n'ont pas compris par
exemple
enfin le retour d'information immédiat
et pour ça ce n'est pas la vidéo à
proprement dit par contre c'est un
support que je rajoute à la vidéo et je
vais vous en parler maintenant un peu
plus en détails pour ça imaginez un jeu
de cartes
pas compliqué imaginez maintenant que
sur chaque carte vous puissiez inscrire
une question au recto une réponse au
verso donc à partir d'un jeu de cartes
complet on peut on revoir l'ensemble la
totalité des questions d'un cours donné
d'une vidéo données avec peut-être 40 50
60 questions donc la totalité
on a imaginé que ces cartes vous
puissiez les numériser ces cartes sont
entièrement numérisé donc accessible sur
n'importe quel support des supports par
exemple téléphones portables tablettes
ordinateurs
imaginez maintenant que ces cartes
puisse avoir du texte des choses écrites
mais également des fichiers audio dire
que la question au lieu de la lyre vous
puissiez brancher un casque écouter et à
voir du coup la question en audio avec
la réponse en audio également que sur
cette carte on puisse avoir également
des schémas des imprimés cran des choses
à annoter y des questions associées au
quai enfin dernière petite chose lié à
ces cartes
imaginez maintenant qu'on couple ces
cartes est un logiciel qui va vous
permettre de les apprendre et de les
répéter
par rapport à un ordre précis liés
à une priorité c'est à dire que les
cartes que vous maîtriser pleinement le
logiciel les connais ne voulait fra -
répété que les cartes que vous maîtrisez
moins bien à ce moment là boum il va
vous les remettre
imaginez ça bon ben ce logiciel il
existe s'appelle en crise d'un logiciel
libre de droits gratuits qui est surtout
utilisée en langue qui est pas connu ou
très peu en sciences et qui est un
logiciel qui est en fait couple est un
algorithme basé sur la courbe de l'oubli
cette courbe de l'oubli donc d'hermann
et bing gosses c'est la courbe que vous
voyez en rouge ici sur votre écran c'est
à dire qu avec le temps s'il en a pas de
deux répétitions et bien on oublie
finalement au fur et à mesure nos
connaissances qui ne sont les moins
consultés il suffirait finalement
d'avoir de temps en temps manière avec
une certaine fréquence la possibilité de
réviser 2ème 3ème 4ème révision pour
finalement diminué cette courbe de
l'oubli et augmenter au contraire la
courbe vertières la courbe des
connaissances permanente
imaginez si vous disposiez de ces outils
là le temps de gagner le stress en moins
ce que vous allez réaliser les choses
efficacement donc finalement demain
l'éducation est ce que par rapport à ce
que je ne vous dira des vidéos couple
est un logiciel ça va remplacer les
cours traditionnels de type en
amphithéâtre par exemple un prof qui
arrive qui expose son cours est-ce que
autrement dit ça va remplacer finalement
l'ensemble des enseignants parce que
finalement si on attend que des vidéos
ça pourrait remplacer ça j'ai envie de
vous dire déjà mais il faut les créer
des contenus vidéo il faut les créer ces
vidéos faut créer que c'est un tout ce
qu'il ya autour bon déjà ça c'est une
première chose mais surtout chose
importante c'est que ça ça peut
permettre de dégager du temps aux
enseignants pour ne pas avoir à répéter
ce type d'enseignement plusieurs fois et
permettre d'en gagner pour réellement
l'utiliser avec des étudiants qui sont
réellement dans le besoin c'est une
chose notamment qui a été fait à
montpellier où des enseignants m'ont
appelé pour dire et finalement tu as
réalisé des vidéos qui aa base que je
dois faire normalement en cours est-ce
que je peux les utiliser et à la place
utiliser ce temps de cours pour faire
plus d'exercice avoir plus
d'applications concrètes finalement
d'être totalement immergé que des
étudiants qui en ont réellement besoin
donc du présentiel mais efficace pas du
présentiel juste
je transmets comme ça donc cet outil là
où ces outils là finalement remplacé non
mais par contre oui supplémentaires oui
complémentaires oui ça peut être une
belle belle avancée enfin est-ce que
finalement ce genre d'outil peut être
utile ailleurs
j'ai envie de dire oui pourquoi pas si
on parle d'entreprises
les entreprises ont obligatoirement
obligatoirement en tout cas
régulièrement forment leurs employés ont
des journées de formation et lorsqu'ils
forment elles ce sont des journées
banalisées avec des intervenants qui
viennent et c est des fois ce sont des
sujets qui peuvent être plus ou moins
intéressants donc imaginez maintenant
c'est une partie de ces informations
sont finalement filmé avec notamment pas
mal d'informations délivrées de cette
manière là ça permettrait aux par
exemple aux employés aux salariés de
pouvoir consulter n'importe où n'importe
quand tout cela quand ils le veulent et
en fonction des sujets qui les
intéressent donc ils peuvent comme ça
continue aussi à se former l'entreprise
peut permettre une formation pour
l'heure pour leurs employés et je pense
également au secteur commercial en
général imaginez dans certains secteurs
les agents commerciaux en des quantités
des quantités de produits à connaître
avec tout un tas de descriptions enfin
une descriptif important et ça pour
ensuite pouvoir discuter avec des
personnes
c'est ça peut être très compliqué pour
aussi une source de stress permanente
lorsqu'ils doivent réviser tout cela est
trop point sur l'ensemble des produits
imaginez quelques vidéos comme ça qu'ils
reprennent les grands produits avec des
questions spécifiques de rappel qui vont
leur permettre de voir avec cet
algorithme basé sur à ça tu maîtrises
moins bien donc on va les réviser
ça tue le maîtrisent mieux donc hop
n'apparaissent pas ses cartes là ça ça
peut vraiment leur faire gagner
énormément de temps et surtout à
permettre d'avoir beaucoup moins de
stress
je vous remercie
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]